I'm talking about the cast of Jersey
Shore they are embarking on another
family vacation tonight and for Mom
Snooki & JWoww well this is a
much-needed getaway like me and jenni
your mom's so like we're 24/7 mom we
never go out and party so when we get
with the roomies we don't have that
responsibility
we appreciate you go wild the wildness
mom's gone wild we are the children for
one yes in season two we've got a
wedding in Vegas
a baby on the way I'm having a baby boy
so I plan on naming him Christopher John
after my husband and my dad and more
meatball power but weird is Snooki and
JWoww husbands think of the moms gone
wild Gianni always says go have a good
time I mean I'm never gonna cheat and
never run across that line but I'm still
a drunk mess and I like to be sloppy
sometimes Fame and my husband doesn't
mind that okay he's like go you're out
of here
live your midlife crisis exactly the
things are faculty what do you compose
sticks I just a lot of fun cuz when I go
home my drama is like my door but that's
my drama now I'm not scared this time
around the drama on screen is nothing
compared to what's happening in real
life Mike the situation is due in court
October 2nd he's facing up to five years
in prison because of tax evasion now
engaged Plus clean and sober almost
three years his mantra is we do recover
life is 10% what happens to 90% how you
react to it
[Music]